Hank: Good morning, John!
John: Good morning, Hank! It's Friday!
Hank: Question Friday; the day that we answer real questions-
John: -from real Nerdfighters. Let's get right to it!
Hank: How many times have you read The Fault in Our Stars?
John: Have I? I don't know...
John: I mean, how many times have I read the finished book?
Hank: Yeah.
John: The- the one that's out in hardcover?
Hank: Yeah, that one.
John: Zero.
John: Why would I read it? There's lots of other books that other people wrote that I could read that I don't remember.
John: How many times have you read it?
Hank: Twice. I read it once before it came out, and once after it came out.
John: Thanks for reading it twice.
Hank: What's your favorite book series at the moment?
John: My favorite book series is always gonna be Harry Potter.
John: I like Divergent a lot though.
Hank: Which one of you would win at an arm wrestling match?
Hank: This is gonna make for a bad video.
(Laughing)
John: Oh, I am gonna lose.
(John shrieking)
(More laughing)
John: I mean,  I could have kept going, but I was laughing so hard.
Hank: Yeah... uh huh... I won with my wit!
John: Did you, Hank, ever cry to one of John's books?
Hank: Yes... I looked at it and I cried to it.
John: I also have cried to one of John's books.
John: If you got to give each other catchphrases what would they be?
Hank: IMAGINE COMPLEXLY!
John: Yours would actually be fart fart fart.
John: How do you like your eggs?
Hank: I like them... inside of a biscuit (John: scrambled)
John: Can you please show us some family photos from when you two were younger?
Hank: It's funny that you should ask because we're in the room that has the photo albums.
John: I don't know if I want people to see this...
Hank: That's pretty cute. You're givin' me a little bear hug.
John: Which one of you is hotter?
Hank: we'll have to have have a poll, like we're not objectively able to...
John: Right, yeah, that's perfect. That's just what I've always needed is a poll to determine whether I'm hotter than my brother.
Hank: Lysh asks: Dance montage?
🎶Comic Sans is the best font in the world🎶
Hank: Do you have pizza on Thanksgiving?
John: No, we have turkey.
Hank: We have normal Thanksgiving.
John: Maybe someday we'll have turkey pizza.
Hank: Favorite kind of pie?
John: Pumpkin.
Hank: Pumpkin also. That's a problem because there's only one pumpkin pie.
John: Is there?
Hank: This Thanksgiving.
John: Oh, almost like The Hunger Games
John: in that one of us is gonna be hungry and the other of us is gonna be dead.
Hank: If John was a turkey and he was the last turkey on earth would you eat him for Thanksgiving?
Hank: No. I mean, are there other foods available? Could I have a ham? But also if John were a turkey I probably wouldn't think very highly of you.
John: I'm just amused by the idea that anyone, no  matter who the turkey was, would eat the last turkey on earth for Thanksgiving.
John: There's only one turkey left and it is Thanksgiving.
Hank: It's like when you find the last Ivory-billed Woodpecker and just be like "Well, who's gonna get to eat this?"
Hank: Could you do drawings of one another?
John: Yeah.
Hank: I did mine.
Hank: It's sparkle pen paper.
Hank: What do you think?
John: Ummm... yeah, I've always wanted a Hanklerfish earring.
John: I drew Hank as well. Um, I drew him as a beaver playing the guitar.
Hank: What's the worst kind of candy?
Hank: I think the worst kind of candy is probably a candy none of us has ever heard of because the person who created it was like "Well, that clearly is poo."
John: One time, uh,  I went to a contemporary art performance at which the artist, who was Chinese, handed out hard candy that tasted like crabs.
John: That... was very bad candy.
Hank: This person just says " Bad jokes".
John: I'd tell you a physics joke but you'd probably find it BOHRing
Hank: But, you know, jokes about Dorian Gray, they never get old.
Hank: Is dftba.com doing anything for Black Friday?
John: Are we? Heck yes! There is three dollar shipping on all orders. No matter how much you order you will get it for just three dollar shipping!
Hank: Even international!
John: What?!
Hank: If you have friends and family who are looking for Christmas presents for you maybe there's something you wanna let them know about.
Hank: How do you make a really good Project For Awesome video?
John: The key to a good Project For Awesome Video is not just like sitting in front of a camera and talking about why a charity is important to you, but actually showing it at work.
Hank: And also consider the fact that you're basically pitching a charity.
Hank: You have to let people know why this is important, why it's a big deal, why it's important to you personally.
John: You know, the best Project for Awesome videos are also videos that the charities themselves can then use
Hank: Yeah!
John: In their own outreach to their donors.
Hank: We love it when that happens, and we hope that it happens a lot this year.
Hank: Have y'all always been really close?
John: No, I mean we've always liked each other though
Hank: Hmm
John: Thank you for watching!
Best wishes!
Hank: DFTBA John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
John: Byee